the world is charged with the grandeur  of god  it will flame out like shining from  shook foil  it gathers to a greatness like the ooze  of oil  crushed why do men then now not wreck  his rod generations have trod  have trod have trod and all is seared  with trade  bleared smeared with toil and bears man  smudge  and shares man's smell the soil is bare  now  nor can foot feel being shod  and yet for all this nature is never  spent  there lives the dearest freshness deep  down things  and though the last lights off the black  west went  ah morning at the brown brink eastward  springs  because the holy ghost over the bent  world  broods with warm breast and with ah  bright wings